Sorry!
I'm sorry.
I was like, whoa.
It's been a...
It's a long time.
Wait, what the heck?
Why is my cursor, like, not synced?
Did you see this?
Oh, weird.
My cursor's not synced with the game.
I wonder if I should restart the game.
Ah!
Yeah.
Let me restart the game.
That's so weird.
So sorry.
Hello.
I hope you enjoyed listening to the intro music.
I hope so.
Hi.
Let's open the game.
Oh.
I hear that?
Hold on.
There we go.
I've actually had that intro music in my head all week.
It's so catchy.
Isn't it so catchy?
I'd listen to it on loop if you uploaded it.
Um, I did.
I did upload it.
I uploaded a one-hour version.
You can listen to it.
I did upload it.
maybe people don't watch my videos no i'm just kidding but yeah i have an upload version of that and the ending music so yeah sorry you're probably like why is a minto chibi minto today is because um i feel like i play these games as chibi kind of like i i don't know much about this game but i heard it's kind of like a like a roulette so i i don't know i just felt like it and then um yeah i can like you know when i get when i strike it rich baby i can yeah
i'm switching shifts soon oh good luck good luck good luck with work
we won't panic i'll never panic lady luck is on my I saw it.
Right, everybody?
The Dev puts it as a baby of Bilatro and Buckshot.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, am I going to sing?
Uh-oh.
Clover Pit.
Um, I didn't, it says continue run, but I did not.
Um, I literally just started it, but it, like, told me a tutorial.
I had to get to the, to the options.
So we'll do new run, obviously.
Wait, where's the tutorial?
Oh, wait, I don't know anything.
Okay, hold on.
Reset tutorial.
Okay.
Okay, next time I'll explain everything again.
Yeah.
Wait.
Restart.
Okay.
I feel like this is a spoiler.
Phone charms.
Spines.
What if I had the god seed?
Again, again!
The fastest run in the West?
Okay, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Wait, hold on.
do I have on this thing?
Hold on.
Hello?
Oh.
It kind of fair.
It's so...
I'll do this voice then.
Hello.
I'll hear you like the gamble.
No need to panic.
You can play and forget about the world.
Now, do you need me to explain how things work around here?
Yeah.
All right.
Listen carefully.
I won't repeat myself.
This is where you must deposit the coins you earn.
I don't get to keep it?
If you can't deposit enough coins within the given number of rounds, well...
You'll find out.
At the end of every round, you'll earn interest based on your current deposited coins.
Keep depositing to earn more.
And if you deposit all the debt early, you'll all reward you with four Clover tickets for every round left.
Now, the slot machine!
You'll decide how many spins to do for each round.
At the end of each round, you will also receive one Clover ticket.
But even more in certain conditions.
You're awesome.
Hey!
Gooba fan!
Remember to spend your Clover tickets to buy Lucky Charms.
Oh!
They improve your odds of surviving.
Is this more tickets?
You spend tickets to get more tickets?
What is this one?
It's only one.
The store restocks for free Whenever you manage to deposit the required coins at the ATM
Well, I'm done talking You won't remember all of it anyway
Okay, I'm back Whoa, what is this?
So why is it a move?
Symbols Get them 7-7-7s, baby!
And, uh...
Don't trust everyone.
Rarity.
Common uncommon rare.
Legendary.
This one, so it's legendary?
I only need one.
Wait, triggers randomly.
20%.
Luck plus 5 for the current spell.
Why does it sound like?
I can't only hear, like, the auto-tune now on my voice.
Yeah.
You can trust me, Minto!
Really?
Okay, I'm giving you my passwords right now.
I'm downloading them to your brain.
I can't hear the auto-tune sometimes.
Okay, I think it's better.
I think it's better.
Fake coin is good.
Hold on, hold on!
Let me read before we start.
Oh, this is common.
Oh, I see now.
Okay, let me read before we start backseating now, okay, you guys?
Okay, hi, dog!
She's played these games before.
She said she's played these games before.
I've played these games before!
Okay, a red pepper.
Why does it glow, though, if it's a common?
Plus, luck plus five for the current spleen.
This card after 12 activations.
Doesn't take... Oh, it's plus... Oh, so you get...
Girl math?
You spend two...
Wait.
Baby car, thank you for the gift.
You get...
Wait.
It's free money.
You spend two to get four, so you get plus two.
So it will be worth enough.
20% chance for bells to have the golden modifier.
Oh, golden modifier scoring a symbol.
Oh, no, I'm already yawning.
It sucks.
It's because I start speaking.
You know, and I like, don't, I don't, well, I spoke a little bit today.
But like, once I start talking, when I use my throat, I get tired.
She is bored of us.
I'm bored.
Wait, this is uncommon.
Triggers randomly.
One extra spin, then luck plus four for that spin.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So what I should do is buy this.
Nol.
Oh, no, not that guy.
I'm still laughing from yesterday's stream.
For those who didn't see, I was on Doki Bird's channel.
And, uh...
That...
Was a stream.
The game is loud?
Gumba.
Lost Gumba.
That's okay.
I...
I'm so...
Ah, well, like, okay, how do I say this?
I think Guba has a lot of potential.
And,
I don't know, I mean, I don't really, I don't expect art of me.
I don't think I'm very sexy.
So, uh, uh, I'm not, like, offended that I lost a Goomba.
At least he didn't lose to Captain Price.
I think if I had lost to Captain Price, Captain Price.
He sounds like the mascot of, like, Walmart.
If I had lost to Captain Price, Doki would have never let me hear the end of it.
Thanks for the recommendation.
Oh, yeah, of course.
I love giving my recommendations.
Eh.
I'm going to start saying weird things about you.
What does that mean?
Captain Price has been...
Oh my god, done!
Done!
Why?
Wait, I didn't get to read it.
Hold on.
One of those types of games I have to like pause.
Happy birthday!
A busy person, work hard, be all your dreams, country, whatever.
Oh, whatever, achieving your goal and remembering the wide blue skies, you are not alone!
Oh, the message from JPEG dog!
Happy birthday to you, Vito Balboa.
I need my burn ocean to the ground.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Learned that Minto like centaurs yesterday.
What?
I'm up, up, home.
I don't, I don't, I mean, like, I don't hate centaurs, but it's not like my, it's not like my, it's not.
If I was given the choice of centaurs, oh my gosh, I thought...
little face on the right side was like that like that out of my face but if i was given a choice between like centaurs and like a couple other things oh wait i was thinking of minotaurs sorry oh yeah i love centaurs sorry anyway what were you saying oh oh minotaurs yeah i'm sorry any oh
Okay.
Should I buy the coin or the bell?
I think I should have some sort of...
This one is uncommon.
Seems better.
Ebery!
Ebery, Ebery, Ebery.
I love you, Ebery.
Thank you for the redirect.
What were you playing?
something milky what was that what what was that what were you playing and moody my beloved oh wait hold on let me let me grab you
no need to feel bad about not being able to compete with perfection of course hi emmody guys i bought emmody a ring we're serious and every time we meet people she's wearing it i'm like i bought her that ring thank you guys for all the gifted thank you so so much thank you thank you thank you
We're like, I bought her that ring.
I bought her that ring.
Who put that ring under your finger, girl?
That big old rock.
Me!
Oh, that's actually not a rock.
It's like slime.
It's official.
Yeah!
Guys, should I get the bell or the coin?
I think I'm going to get the bell.
Because I...
Wait, I can get both!
I'm going to get both.
All in, baby.
Who should I call?
Okay.
What's this now?
Login.
Oh!
One trick pony.
Grants one jackpot.
at the slot machine, then discard this charm.
Unlockable by dying?
Ah, these are unlockables that you give when you die.
My birthday was the 30th!
Jessica, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Jessica!
Who are you?
Happy birthday!
Seven sins stone.
Oh, necklace.
Hello, for bell.
Hello.
23 pages?
Wait, what's this guy?
Discovered.
It's 30% chance.
Wait, how do I... Oh.
How do I get it?
I already have it, apparently.
Wait, why do I... Oh, here we go.
Oh!
Well...
Oh, baby...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, my job here is done.
Thank you!
We inspect the...
Oh, we can read this.
Oh, it's credits!
And then I'm guessing this takes me to steam.
That's cute.
Wait, what about this?
Oh, okay.
I can only read...
fall.
Minto Captain Price Gumba Love Triangle.
I think I don't stand a chance against their love.
Lucky Chan.
What's that thing?
Hello?
I'm afraid I can't let you do that!
Okay.
Open.
Oh, oh, this is a...
Okay.
I should have known that.
Inspect.
Oh!
Oh, it's about golden...
Bell.
Pick an option.
There we go.
Oh, okay, so the things that you have on your...
That you are actively using are on your desk, I suppose.
No interest.
Okay, this is where we put our money.
So we gotta get...
Good amount of money.
What is this now?
That's your final reward.
I still haven't decided when you'll get it.
Oh.
Guys, don't look.
No way.
I've seen obviously number one in a game, but I've never seen a number two.
Don't look.
I had Taco Bell.
Technology has gotten too far.
Oh, I'm shaking.
Oh god.
Ah!
Oh my god, what did I get?
Looks like you discovered a new lucky charm.
Check out the terminal to learn more.
I broke my toilet!
Oh my god!
Wait, it...
Wait!
Number two...
Oh, no!
It's gold.
Triggered by red button.
all patterns with non-yellow symbols will trigger an additional time.
Okay.
What?
Huh?
Oh.
Oh my god, my dumpy broke the toilet!
I mean...
That is...
Something...
What is that thing?
Okay, that...
I mean, everybody expected that.
Okay, let's just...
How many spins?
Wait, so we're trying to get...
35?
45?
At least?
Not sure if you've seen it, but there's a DLC for Resident Evil 7 called 21.
You play a twisted version of...
Blackjack!
That sounds so fun.
45.
Let's try...
Okay, so we use the coin we minus the coins okay always seven really yeah well you only get okay I see I see because if you do three spins it's more risk and higher reward and it costs less but it's more risk let's try seven though it's my first time let's go gambling let's go gambling how much did I get
I think we've won?
I think we've...
I think we're jackpot?
Why is that one speed?
Oh, okay.
I can do that to all of them.
Triggers.
Oh, okay.
I'll try that next time.
I don't remember what my things do.
I think that's the issue.
Triggers randomly.
Okay, one extra spin, then lock.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then you.
Neither of them are for the button.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
This is so exciting!
Ah, dang.
Oh, lemon, lemon, baby!
No spins left.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Deadline bonus, so if I give my stuff now, I'll get more things, right?
Good job.
How about another deadline?
Now you need to reach the amount of 200.
Here's your deadline bonus.
Don't say I never treat you.
By the way, the cost to play the slot machine increases.
After every deadline!
Whoa.
Whoa, we got some crazy stuff going on over here.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
Whoa, whoa.
Hello?
How are things going?
Please, I'll give you anything.
I used to eat healthy.
Can I eat something?
Diamonds.
Oh, wow!
Wait, this is kind of crazy.
Wait, I wish...
Hold on, maybe I should put my head somewhere.
Hmm.
Okay.
So you guys can read these too.
The diamonds manifest more often plus one permanently.
Cherries manifest more often.
So we need to kind of decide what sort of...
We need bells.
I think bells would be good.
Lucky charms at the store are discounted by two tickets until the next restock of the store.
We had some...
Uh, be right back.
Okay, we had some things here.
So I want to see what they are.
Why is this one glowing?
special, but it says it's common.
Okay, I get it, I get it.
Wait, this one's rare.
Triggered by the red button.
Sevens manifest more often, plus two for the rest of the current deadline.
Consumes all charges when triggered.
Recharges by one charge at the end of every round.
Whatever three plus patterns trigger during a spin, you earn money equal to your current interest.
Okay.
Charms with triggers randomly activate.
Double more often!
Okay, wait.
Because I have two.
No?
This one triggers randomly.
For sure.
So, cat is good.
Okay.
I have nine tickets.
And what was this one?
Pentacle.
Gambler.
Okay.
Gain one free restock every deadline.
Symbols multiplier plus one.
This bonus grows by one whenever five plus patterns triggered during a spin.
And then I guess this is the...
Okay, restock.
Okay, got it.
Why is this one rare, though?
I feel like Horseshoe is kind of good.
Also, it says plus 3% to my interest.
But I don't want to buy these yet Because we have a thing That will discount our stuff At the store That's why I said be right back So maybe I do this And then we can get a couple things We're cooking We're cooking, we're cooking, we're cooking Because I don't know what kind of like build I want to do I don't even know that that's what I could do I don't know Okay,
let's do that then.
You don't even have money for food!
Interesting data.
Okay, okay, okay.
Free!
The cat is free!
Oh my gosh!
Free cat!
That was the cat distribution center?
Honestly, I could get all of these.
I don't know how many things I can have on...
Oh, three out of seven.
Okay, okay.
That answered my question.
Literally immediately.
I don't know this, though.
What does the charge mean?
What the hell is that?
Where did that...
Was that always there?
We got some apple juice?
Let's go.
Huh.
This is all you've said at the phone.
Oh, okay, okay, fun.
Alright.
How are the cats doing anyway?
Um, Merrill is good.
She's silly, silly.
Um, Butaro is uh, not doing so well, unfortunately.
Yeah.
Um, I don't really want to talk about it right now.
I meant Paj.
Oh no, I said her legal name.
I literally just doxxed my cat.
That's okay.
I never use her names anyways.
I always call her little girl.
I call her little girl.
Yeah, don't, don't.
You guys stop.
I know that this is so surprising for you.
Look at your name.
Did you expect anything else?
Honestly, I was deciding between the two of them.
So...
Because...
But I feel like Paz suits her more.
Actually, I wanted to name her Johnny.
Because...
She, like, poops on the ground.
She has, like, really...
She has, like, really bad, like, bowel issues.
My cat has IBS, maybe.
I've honestly thought about even changing it to Johnny.
I've called, but in the end, I've, I've, like, I've really just called her girl.
So, also, wait, I just saw, hold on.
Oh, my gosh, I'm so sorry.
I just saw the pink.
Super late.
Because time's on shenanigans.
But happy belated birthday.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Copta fubo and slippers.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh.
Um, for anybody, uh, for the merch.
Um, uh, I was talking to Setsuna today.
And they were thinking of a way to make shipping cheaper for those, uh, in, EU so that potentially might be a thing they're working on it so um uh uh um yeah your cat's real name is G Koyo Octopus but yeah so um if that is able to happen they will announce it um so yeah um Remember that time I said far when you're cute?
Wait, what?
Far?
Did I read that right?
Leha, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay, alright, there we go.
Alright, okay, cool.
Oh, yeah, I was still buying these.
Okay, I'm gonna think I'm gonna buy these two.
And then I...
I don't know what the charges are.
But it wouldn't...
Seven manifests more often, plus two for the rest of the current deadline.
Charges used by the button.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
That's why.
Triggered by a red button.
Oh!
Consumes all charges when triggered.
Recharges by one charge at the end of it.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Should I get it?
I have four left.
Why not?
Happy Labor Day.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I fill up the item to use on the button.
Yeah, oh yeah.
I can always sell it.
It's only two.
I'd get what, one back?
I will only have one slot left though afterwards.
Why is this one like blinking?
I don't like it.
Oh, I have some mail.
I've unlocked a necklace!
Whenever you score, only one pattern with either diamonds or treasures.
It triggers it two additional times.
The final trigger rewards.
It doubles the coins.
Okay.
You should use the toilet.
Again?
I already used it.
Okay, I'll pee.
You're good.
my god achievement take a piss and a dump
i unlocked number one i like how it says do not drink
during this round all patterns with yellow symbols will trigger an additional time oh
by pressing the button Wait, what's an additional time mean?
Now we know Mint wouldn't last, that's true.
Petition to rename Wisps to as Pisps.
No!
I hate that.
Denied, denied, denied.
The pattern will score twice.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Thank you.
I think I'm gonna hold off on the seven, even though it's so tempting because it's a rare.
I think I'll hold off.
thing for the button.
But I mean, I know I can probably get more than one thing on the button.
Oh.
Wow.
Are you getting my best side?
You need to drink more water, Minto.
I'm drinking water right now.
The bell charm.
This one?
Nope.
Brown super chat.
Thank goodness.
Let's just go for it.
We need 200.
Oh, maybe I should.
I should get the seven.
I don't know.
You could go for bells.
Because we have what, oh, if we get the yellow, if we get the P. If we get the P, then we could go for a yellow build.
Oh, yeah, yellow build.
Really hydrated.
Why did it come out like mustard?
I don't know.
Okay, let's try the yellow build seven spins oh gosh it goes up it goes up it goes up oh look how many lemons are oh okay next lucky not enough what's E oh it's just so I can look Okay.
BING!
Ah!
Sevens!
Big, big!
Why do I feel like I'm not getting good stuff?
Send out this super chat feels like such a relief for- No!
Oh my god!
No!
Thank you.
We still have two rounds left, okay?
We still have two rounds.
So, should I deposit everything?
Maybe.
I gotta go cuddle my cat.
I'll have fun.
Like, when should I deposit?
When is the good time to do?
Deposits make your cat stronger.
What's my cat at now?
My current interest is...
Oh, whenever 3 plus patterns trigger during a spin, you earn money equal to your current interest.
Seven.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
So I'm gonna...
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, okay, I see.
Okay.
Don't you know if we're talking about P too much or too little?
I think way too much.
I mean I hope you're doing good, but you have your breakfast today.
Today I had
Oh, meal.
How much is a seven spins?
14.
Okay, so we'll deposit until we have 14.
This is good.
Okay.
I think we'll make it still.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, bink, bink!
If I hold down...
No, it doesn't do anything.
Oh god.
Why did it hesitate?
Ah, please!
Why do I feel like my multipliers are not doing anything?
Hello?
Oh!
Big buddy!
Meow!
Okay.
Yes, sir.
Yes, sir, yes, sir.
Wait, so it's still...
Okay, it's still 14.
It'll go up after...
You can now encounter the pattern 666.
If you score it at the slot machine, you'll lose...
All buddy in that route.
Why did they...
Why did they do that?
the amount of six six six oh
my god want to have some fun i don't care about the price make two random lucky charms in the store free set your tickets to zero oh give me my give me back my money double your coins set your tickets to zero i've already bet it uh have the base chance to manifest diamonds,
treasures, and sevens
This one seems maybe the best.
Be right back.
What do we have here?
Cat food!
Treasure picture.
Snake eyes.
Thank you for the super tight.
Treasures manifest more often, plus two for the rest of the current deadline.
Consumes all charges when triggered.
Recharges one at the end of every round.
Grandma's purse.
Interest increases by 15% but decreases by 3% after every round.
15%.
Oh, ew.
Discard this charm when its bonus is zero.
Oh, we got the number two!
But we need the number one.
We need the number one.
Purs is pretty good, is it?
Oh my gosh, this sound is so annoying.
I don't want to set my tickets to zero.
Wait.
How much are they?
I feel I will be at a loss.
I would be at a complete loss.
I was able to watch a birthday concert while on a trip.
In the middle of nowhere, Minnesota.
Wow, thank you for watching.
Enjoy your camping trip.
One free restock.
Yeah, but like...
These don't seem bad.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I think I'm gonna do this half the base chance.
Oh wait.
Oh, it half's the base chance.
Oh, I didn't read it properly.
Oh, these suck.
Oh my god.
No!
These are terrible.
I guess re-roll, but we lose two tickets.
Hmm.
you don't have to take a red call you can ignore it but it's so annoying the little bink bink bink bink bink bink half equals more bells okay okay
that is that is an option if we want the bell build Spend tickets in double money?
Wait, yeah, that's a good idea too.
Yeah, actually we'll do that.
Because I think that would be way better.
Actually.
Um, be right back.
I think cat food...
I don't know.
We have two slots left.
So we have to make it count.
I can't hear the phone from back here.
And then I can reset too.
Is there any of these that you think I just...
None of us treasured...
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
Granny purse and cat food is what you guys are saying.
I can reroll for free even.
So...
Hmm.
Two more spins is good.
It is good.
You guys are right.
The purse The purse I guess is a nice Temporary thing Right Is there anything here that I'm like Anymore
One free restock Oh this is the pentacle is giving me the restock
This bonus grows by one Whenever five plus patterns Triggered during a spin I don't think I've had any of that I don't think I've had any of that I don't think that's happened to me yet.
Charms will trigger randomly activate double more often.
That's right.
And 3% of my interest.
So horseshoe, good, good, good.
What was this one?
This one's good too.
Oh, and the coin.
Everything so far is okay.
So the bell maybe.
The bell.
The bell is a nice...
If we have a bell build, then it kind of works.
Compounding interest in this game is really good.
I think I will go with Garam.
I don't want to lose the rest of my tickets.
I would like to spend them on something bigger, but it would be good to have more interest.
And it'll disappear eventually, so...
But we could just...
You know what?
I think I'll re-roll.
Let's see what we get.
Lost a briefcase.
Doesn't take space.
Immediately earned 30% of the money.
of the debt amount.
Oh?
And it doesn't take space?
Holy Bible.
Ambitious.
Patterns multiplier plus one.
If a 666 is going to trigger, transforms it into a normal symbols.
Then you have 50% chance of discarding this charm.
I see.
Hmm.
No, don't.
Triggers randomly.
Wait, I got the red pepper before, didn't I?
Maybe.
I got a pepper before.
Fluck plus five for the current spin.
Discard after 12 activations.
And then mushrooms.
During every spin increases all symbols by their base value for every pattern triggered after the second...
Resets at the end of every round.
So what if we did...
So this doesn't take up space?
It actually doesn't?
So I could get both.
these the bible and the briefcase
it's broken let's go well we're trying to use up all of my tickets anyway so and then we double our money
thank you
nice oh we i think we actually have enough money we don't even need to spend do we Hi!
Thank you, Vito.
You're welcome!
I don't do much, I'm just here.
How much is it?
28.
Wait.
The 666.
Oh, oh!
Oh my gosh, I lost track!
Okay, it didn't let me, it didn't let me put in anymore.
Okay, cool.
My interest.
Okay, alright.
We're building interest.
Wow!
Easy!
Um...
Should I do the three spins?
Because if I do the three spins, I get more...
Tickets.
And I get two extra spins.
So...
Mero, thank you so much for the...
Retherwork, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
You don't have space for anything though.
I guess that's true.
The most valuable thing you can give someone is a bit of your time.
What?
Okay, I guess seven.
I guess seven.
Let's go gambling.
Wee!
Oh!
Yippee!
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
That scared me.
Doop doop.
Uh-oh.
I got lucky once.
I got lucky once and never again.
Okay.
No way.
Badoop.
Oh my
god!
Oh, oh, father!
Thank you!
Wait, it says put things in the drawer.
What does that mean?
Can I get them back?
Holy cow!
Lucky, I was lucky once.
We got a fruit basket.
What's that do?
And Book of Shadows.
Oh my gosh.
Corpse part.
Wait, these are two.
I love fruits basket anime.
And then I love corpse party.
1.5% chance of seeing a 666.
Whenever you see a 666.
You gain plus three spins.
And then plus two.
And then plus one.
10 plus 0!
Resets to plus 3.
Spins at round end.
That's scary.
Patterns with fruits trigger an additional time.
Discard after seven rounds.
Oh, I see.
Well, right now we're still kind of faux.
Um, I think I'll deposit the rest.
Wow, okay.
You can never have enough, am I right?
You now need to reach the amount of...
2,222!
Oh!
How are things going?
Increase the amount...
This really is Bellatro, isn't it?
This is... This really is if Bellatro and Buckshot Roulette had a baby!
Increase the value of patterns with three or less symbols by their base value.
I need to be there!
Bells manifest more often!
Plus one permanently.
I need money!
Treasures manifest more often permanently.
Okay, so we're going with the bell strat, so...
Bells!
That's something you used to say a lot, right?
I don't...
My FOMO.
And then what's this?
Bells manifest more often plus two for the rest of the current deadline!
This is the diamonds.
Oh, we got a rare.
This one's rare.
Oh, it's number two!
That's why.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
bells bells bell picture but like what do I replace it with you know and also I asked the question that I never looked if I put something if it's like put in drawer I can take it back out later right can't wait for the blanket to get sent out gonna put on my gaming chair for extra coffee this I'm so excited you need number one for the yellow yeah yeah yeah we need number one and if we get this bell picture?
Be good.
Oh, you need to unlock the drawer.
Wait, so...
How do I unlock it?
You don't have the key.
Is this the key to the drawer?
Oh, it's this!
Oh, it's these!
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Okay.
I understand.
Chat.
Is this real?
Wait.
Oh!
Real?
Chat!
Chat.
Is this real?
Don't make me take my meds.
What do we do then?
What do we do?
I like the one free restock, but I think this is our weakest link at the moment.
Gonna need a big red circle to figure out what you're talking about.
Do you see it?
Uh...
I
think the pentacle needs to be thrown away.
The cat isn't needed right now.
No, I think the cat is pretty good.
I think.
I think the cat is good.
The cat is an investment.
The cat is something that we grow and nurture.
Coin?
One extra spin, then luck plus four for that spin.
Hmm.
I feel like I need the luck.
I feel like I need the luck, but...
Well, we're gonna have to get rid of two things eventually, huh?
Only 10% chance.
I think that's a pretty high chance, no?
Alright, goodbye.
Wait, why don't I get anything for it?
If I put...
Oh, okay.
There is no drawer available.
All right.
Goodbye coin.
It's 20% with the horseshoe.
Oh, that's right!
That's right.
Don't you have a charm that gives you sevens?
No, I did not buy that.
I did not buy it.
Ah, cat food!
My plus two spins!
we could eat the cat food.
Minkidie.
I think we'll get it again.
It's pretty common, it seems.
So, okay.
I didn't expect the cat food to be so juicy.
All right, let's get some coins.
All right, so I have to remember to use this stinking...
button then what so is the best thing to do is to just press it immediately
oh my gosh you're so eager yeah okay push the button okay okay
um i'm gonna deposit some stuff how much is it 42 okay even though it seems to Wow, it's a lot.
Oh, exactly 42!
Okay.
Oh, that's the...
Okay, so I press it now, or...
When do I press it?
Now.
Oh, it won't let me.
Okay.
Here.
Okay, trigger!
Oh, we got something new.
Look at all these lemons.
Whoa!
Big body!
Wait, so do I press it again?
When do I press it?
Like, uh, I can't tell what the charge is at.
It's active?
Is it because of this?
Okay.
It'll light up.
Okay, okay.
Thank you, thank you.
Beep beep Nice Okay Ah dang
No spins left Okay Okay okay plus 95 Plus 95 Alright Okay Alright Alright Nice I also said maybe I should re...
Oh, here, hold on.
Let's do this.
We got a car battery.
Immediately restore all charges on equipped Lucky Charms.
Triggerable by the red button.
Okay, interesting.
I guess because we used it for the first time.
Let's see what we got here.
Stonks!
5% to your interest.
Golden diamond.
I don't care.
Red pepper gambler.
Come.
Grandma's purse.
We got them Stonks?
We got them stonks?
Stonks fits cat build.
It does.
But what would I get rid of?
Do we stop being a bell build?
Do we stop the bell build and just become a stonks build?
If that were the case, I wish I'd get the cat food.
No, why my horseshoe?
It's 3% of my interest.
gonna get rid of the horseshoe you guys it's got a special it's got the specialness on it we gotta have the three percent extra yeah yeah yeah because it has like uh the shiny on it it's a shiny horseshoe what's the so the coin it is
I think maybe the coin.
You guys are right that it doesn't show up so, so often.
Goodbye, coin.
Why is it so juicy?
We got stonks.
Stonks, stonks, stonks, stonks.
We got stonks, stonks, stonks, stonks.
Let's go gambling.
Okay, so it's still activated in the corner.
Oh.
I was excited.
Lemon.
Nice.
I want to get a jackpot.
Oh, I see the thing here now.
Okay, interesting.
Okay, okay.
Interesting.
144 is still huge though, I think.
Yes, sir, yes, sir.
Uh-oh.
Is it huge enough, though?
Is it huge enough?
Oh, wait.
It might be okay.
I think we're good.
Should I try one for more?
Wonder if
One more round Keep farming?
That's what I'm thinking
Yeah, look at my Oh Look at my bell We gotta make the bells more We gotta get them bells up, baby
And it's good because we'll recharge this too So that we can That we can Get it back up Okay
My uncle Tony said I should stay away from VTubers as they corrupt the soul.
He's wrong because you have the makings of a varsity athlete.
I do!
Thanks, Chris.
Alright, 7 Spoon...
Wait.
Oh, part of me wants to deposit...
If I deposit more, will I hit the...
Amount?
Oh, deposit 111.
Uh, no.
Okay, okay, that's the max we can do.
Okay, okay, there we go.
Let's go gambling.
Quasimodo predicted all this.
What are you talking about?
keep doing this to me?
Why do they keep doing this to me?
Holy money!
Holy big bucks, baby!
Oh!
We do still have the Bible.
We do.
Big payout!
This is your last chance to deposit your coins now!
Yes, sir.
12,000!
Seems like a fair amount to reach your final reward?
Mushy, mushy!
I can't quit now.
Double jackpot's value.
Diamonds manifest more often, permanently.
Double the value of lemons and cherries.
No!
Oh yeah, we're gonna re-roll here.
It's expensive!
It's four!
It's four tickets.
I only have nine.
Yeah, I'm gonna check the charms first.
Whoa!
That thing's crazy looking.
Grant's luck plus seven for the last spin of a round.
Number two again?
Where is my number one?
Mushrooms again.
Car battery.
Oh!
It doesn't take space.
Oh, but it's still too.
I do have full charms, but I could, like, take it and then reroll.
There could be something, like, you know, good that shows up.
At the end of every deadline, earn one one ticket for every three you own.
Clover pet.
The hell is that thing?
Oh, it's like a little or a garmy.
Yeah, I did have the bell charge three fourths, so yeah, yeah, yeah.
You want interest in bells really.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Symbols multiplier plus one for every five you own.
Oh.
The hand calls.
No!
hand no deal no deal can i still pee in this and like will it give me stuff okay let's re-roll on this it's minus four so
bells manifest more often yeah baby that's what i'm talking about Woo!
Woo, woo, woo!
Okay!
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
12,000 is a heckin' ton of it.
Okay.
But we're getting the interest.
Nice.
Beep-beep!
Alright, here we go!
Oh!
Have you ever been to a real casino?
Never!
I've never been to a real casino before!
I think I would win.
Yeah.
Oh, this is not good.
this isn't good i think with my luck i should not go
yeah yeah yeah
okay nice nice and nice nice and nice
okay Wait, how much is it?
56.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Get that interest.
Let's go.
Get boy.
What the heck is that?
I got mail.
Why do you keep doing this to me?
Oh,
big money.
Up into a real casino in Reno, the only way to win is to play the penny slots and just rake in free drinks for as long as your money lasts.
Wait, you can play for just a penny?
What?
Really?
That sounds...
I could just go outside and find a penny and come back in.
And then I win more.
We still have them.
This is messed up.
Oh, man.
That was terrible, guys.
That was no good.
Oh, no.
Oh, my.
Oh, whoops.
We gotta make...
This is not good.
We'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
I got 12 coins.
Yeah, we love to see it.
We love the bells.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm not scared anymore.
I'm not scared anymore!
Always believe in bell build.
Thank you!
The deadline is now!
Okay.
Oh, not now.
It won't let me do it anymore.
That's funny.
Awesome.
Awesome, awesome.
Yay!
And it looks like you've earned your reward.
Go get it!
Oh.
More?
Okay.
So does that unlock?
Do you want to keep playing?
Yes?
I like your winner mentality.
Go on!
Oh.
Wait, open this.
Wait, I guess I... Wait, could I have begun the game?
Wait.
Wait, could I have... Could I have... Could I have left?
Is this her first run?
Yes.
That's... Wait.
What if I just unplug it?
I've earned the electrician.
Plus 5% chance for the battery modifier to be applied to any symbol.
Decrease by 1% at the end of every round.
What?
Okay, shut up!
Shut up!
Double the value of lemons, cherries.
Lucky charms at the store are discounted by two tickets until the next restock.
I will be right back.
Megaphone.
that you pick up at the telephone trigger one more time.
It's a legendary.
I don't have enough.
And I'm still full.
Actually, the Bible is like holding on to dear life.
Last three deadlines, then discard this charm.
At the end of each deadline gives as many tickets as the deadlines left to this charm.
Now three, okay.
You guys said the Bible's not worth it, but the Bible has saved my butt, baby.
Put the mega in storage.
You're so right.
Okay, so we'll buy it and we can put it in the drawer.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Because then if we can get more diamond stuff.
Okay, I'm not going to do the phone.
I'm not going to do the phone.
Because I would have to re-roll.
Oh, wait.
Wait a second.
Yo, I can make things discounted!
I can discount them and then I can buy it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
So we'll discount it.
Okay, thank you.
And then we'll get you.
Make some space.
Before equipping other garbage.
Info.
It's just a drawer.
You can put things inside of it.
Oh, I have to put something.
Okay, do I have to switch it out?
Alright.
Put in drawer.
Okay.
Bye.
Put in drawer.
Oh, wait.
Uh.
Equip.
I can't just swap them.
I think the Pentacle can go.
But I like our free restock.
It's quite nice.
Our free restock has been pretty good.
Congrats on your birthday.
Thank you.
It's on the road during the live stream, so I missed info.
Where do I redeem this voucher?
Whom?
Horseshoe!
You guys!
The horseshoe is giving us plus three interest!
We are on an interest run!
Shut your mouths!
Unless I get something else that will give me even more interest, we're keeping the horseshoe!
What do you mean Bell not needed anymore?
We- we- we're- we have a Bell build!
What are you talking about?
Well, I guess it is only plus three coin, huh?
Whatever.
You're supposed to build it up, but I don't get any.
This one doesn't actually add that much, huh?
This one's like really in for the long haul.
Hmm.
Adds to the value of the bell, but only sometimes.
Only sometimes.
Wait, why do I have six slots now?
Wait, what happened?
Huh?
Oh, my Bible.
Oh, God, I'm going to die.
I'm going to lose it all.
I'm gonna lose it!
Oh, megaphone is minus one slot.
Anyway, well, we'll just hope and pray.
We'll just hope and pray.
140.
I guess it does let you.
Let's just see where...
Let's do this round and see what we're looking like.
Let's go.
You know?
I really don't know what is...
Oh, okay.
That's it.
Oh, I can't trigger it yet, can I?
Not yet.
Oh, my battery.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
This is fine.
This is good.
Holy cow!
Don't do this to me.
76.
Oh, come on.
Well, we did hit it big enough.
in that first one, so.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Now what do we have here?
Raging capitalist!
Three?
How do you get this?
Scoring 30 times any modified luck or bell in a single run.
3% chance.
Oh, plus 3% chance for the ticket modifier.
What is that?
to be applied to any symbol raises by 1% every time you buy a lucky charm interesting this thing is so annoying shut up why are you shaking like that okay now we can press the bell button okay cool oh hold on so uh the sick if we get the 666 it loses We lose all the money that we're currently holding on to.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Okay.
The 7K.
Right.
So.
Okay.
Why is it letting me deposit?
Wait, how much do I have?
Oh, it's 100.
Okay.
Wait.
Why is it letting me deposit more?
That's scary.
Wait, what?
No, I was at 5 spins.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Ah!
Yo, you said.
to stop me before.
Now it's not.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
I understand now.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
It changed.
Oh my gosh.
Scary.
Scary!
It didn't tell me!
Oh!
You have learned.
I learned!
You guys can't get mad at me.
How could I know?
Alright.
We need still a lot.
Scary.
Okay.
I got mail.
Help!
Getting ice cream.
Do you want chocolate or waffle crunch?
Chocolate!
Not good.
Not good!
Bad, bad.
Oh, very bad.
Oh,
but I got plus 4,000.
I forget that we get the interest at the end.
Honestly?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, okay.
With the interest, I think we'll be okay.
interest!
I'm gonna spin this, because we have it.
Book of Shadows.
Come.
Hmm.
Do you see that amount?
That's right, right?
Oh yeah, what's here, too?
button all lucky charms triggered by the red button trigger one more time oh negative one to charms so legendary it seems maybe legendary charms take up a space interesting that was a lot of money that was a lot of money we could skip this round i think it might honestly be safer so that i can Get more...
I don't know.
Do a short run?
But what if I lose it all?
What if I lose it all?
Interest will cover you.
Yeah, that's true, that's true.
That's true, that's true.
But it's so much money I'll lose.
Okay, let's go gambling.
Seven spins?
Three spins.
Oh!
Stop!
Seven.
Let's go gambling.
Let's go, gambling!
Scary, scary, scary, scary, scary Let's go, gambling!
And last spin!
I'm going to Vegas!
I'm
going to Vegas, baby!
Oh my gosh, we're already halfway there.
Whoa!
We're already halfway there!
Whoa, whoa!
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Oh, my bad.
That's not what I meant to do.
Um...
What we got going on here?
Oh, we got the capitalist guy.
Ra- Oh, no, that's raging.
That's- It's like- It's like raging Raven.
Your greed sickens me.
3% to my interest!
20% chance for Clovers to have a golden modifier.
No, no, no!
Luck plus 5 on next spin if the previous two had no reward.
Plus 2 extra luck for every in-sequence activation after the first one.
Minto and her lair.
Please.
No.
Oh, I can't reroll, you guys.
I can't reroll.
We could do this one.
Increases the value of patterns with three or less symbols.
That overall helps.
So, I think that's the one we should go with.
I'm thinking of some strategies.
Yeah, alright.
This is still loading.
I couldn't re-roll because I do not have enough tickets.
It was, um, it was, uh, it was six tickets.
But I will re-roll here.
Oh, I mean, I don't have any space.
I don't have any space.
It's very scary.
How much is it?
Mine, okay.
Hope for a battery.
That's a good, that's a good plan.
Let's try that.
Bada-dang!
Nothing.
Let's go gambling.
Wow this would have been great wait we're 3,000 away I think we're interest is literally gonna cover us so I think we're gonna be okay that was my last spin wasn't it
You naughty!
Dump the megaphone.
The megaphone!
Actually, just remember how we did that plus one to each thing?
Actually, it doubled it, so it's not so bad.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh!
I want a jackpot!
Well, my very first Japan trip and go to Haki Haribaru today as the resident expert.
Is there any places you think are must-see?
Ah, wait.
Do you like grapes?
It's grape season right now, right?
For fruits?
Fruit, fruit, fruit de season is a great parfait place.
I love it.
I think it's grapes right now.
Hold on.
Let me see.
Let me see what the...
They have like a little...
Calendar.
Fruits do season.
I can't remember that.
Not tabi log.
Where's your calendar at?
What happened?
I always recommend this place.
It's so yummy.
Maybe I should write it in Japanese.
Food.
Season.
There we go.
A I feel so French when I say it.
Yeah, Budo Parfait, it has started.
Wait, that's 9th.
Wait, wait, wait.
Ah!
I think it's a grapes.
French.
I can't find the calendar.
It says, budo, that's grape.
Budo, perfect.
But, let me click menu.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
It is still, okay, so you can get, uh, oh.
What the heck is that?
You can get grapes or you can get, I think this is a Japanese pair.
Yes, I believe that's Japanese pair, and then there's one other thing, but I don't recognize what that is.
Persimmon, maybe?
Hmm, so there's three different parfaits you can get in October.
Wow.
Anyways, gambling?
Wait, but my...
But my...
If I deposit this, it will go over, right?
Oh, my entry.
though yes
keep farming okay I'm still scared this is a lemonade stand we don't sell grapes I love why don't they make grape lemonade let's go gambling hi come on Show mommy the money!
Lucky!
Oh, we got a new item.
That's fun.
This game is so fun.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I...
I got something.
Something just happened.
Oh, it's recharged.
That's what that meant.
What if we unlock an iron?
wrong 20 chance for the any bell to have the ticket modifier unlockable by scoring 50 modified bells oh
uh what does this modifier do oh wait it literally tells me ticket modifier scoring a symbol with this modifier earns you a ticket
i don't want to lose 41 000 i'm scared Ah!
How scared!
You won't.
But if I get 666, I will.
Oh, 666 is only current spin round.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, you only lose in the...
So I can't lose all of this.
Oh!
I thought I lost everything that was in my pockets!
Like they took me by my ankles and shook me out.
Oh.
I see.
The reason why I'm not cashing this in right now is because if I deposit it, I'm immediately going into the next round.
So we're farming a little bit.
But I think it would be good to get some more tickets.
But we're fine too.
We're fine too.
Okay.
Let's go gambling.
Hi.
maybe i should have saved that um you know maybe i'm stupid whatever save the button for next round uh too late it's okay we're just gonna get a lot of money baby oh i completely forgot that we were like on the last round um don't worry about it
thank you
Don't worry about it.
We got a lot of money.
I think we're okay.
What happens next if I don't put in the money?
What happens next?
200,000?
Oh, it's still only 196.
Okay.
I think...
I don't know if I should take any of these.
I have cherries manifest more often, diamonds manifest more often, and sevens manifest more often.
I can't reroll, unfortunately.
I don't have enough tickets.
Hold on, I'm gonna move my head, like maybe here.
This is a better spot.
Maybe?
Don't take any?
I think so.
What do we have here?
Oh!
Wait.
It's... Oh!
Wait!
We get free money!
And that would be enough to reroll!
Well, lucky time triggers during a spin raise this bonus by one.
If nothing triggers, reset this bonus.
bad.
I have enough room.
I'm gonna re-roll here, though, and see what we get.
Oh, we got the nuclear button.
All lucky terms triggered by the red button triggered one more time.
That'd be crazy.
Do you guys think I should re-roll?
Yeah, you're right.
We do have to use the The megaphone.
We have it.
Add the florid trait to a random lucky charm.
Restore all charm.
Oh.
Um.
Wait, this is good because we...
I accidentally used it.
So...
Um.
But then...
With this, I would get it on two different things.
When dead...
Oh, this is tough.
Because the megaphone would double it.
That is a lot.
That would be like plus four every time.
Two is good for long term.
I agree.
Double jackpot's value.
I haven't gotten jackpot even once.
I don't know what the value is.
Okay, let's go.
What's this one then?
Are we betting colors now?
Whoa!
Everything's so shiny!
Plus two when deadline ends.
Plus two when deadline ends!
Let's go!
Awesome.
And we're at 22,000.
So I need 50,000 to win.
Let's go.
I did accidentally use this.
My bad.
Yeah, I am getting mad interest.
It's kind of insane.
It's kind of super insane.
Oh, don't scare me.
Come on, cat.
I need you.
Still not bad.
insane it's actually insane oh my gosh
let's see this would will this put me no wait will this put me over
oh wait no just kidding I just saw how much I had okay just kidding I was gonna sorry I'm not I'm not good I'm not good at math.
I'm not good at math.
Wait, you couldn't see?
Oh, my bad.
I'm so sorry.
Wow, this...
This is pretty terrible.
That's okay.
We're fine.
Yikes.
Yikes forever.
Just kidding.
okay that will put me oh okay i'm i'm blocking maybe um let me put myself to the left actually
maybe here i'll be good trying to stay out of the way for you guys as much as possible
okay okay all right cool sorry we're learning we're learning this game is so much fun oh no I can't deposit though because this will put me over a hundred percent so we keep going let's go gambling let's go gambling height
it's a shock me every time.
It seriously shocks me every time.
I love a bell move.
Imagine if I lost it all.
Thank you.
Deposit your coins now or you'll find out what happens next okay okay you don't scare me
beep beep oh so much so so much awesome awesome awesome 12 plus 4 okay let's see what you have
wait that it was a million wait what'd you say Why?
That's insane.
Cool.
Let's double the value of clovers and bells.
Let's go.
Yes.
And actually, that will even double it more because I have the megaphone.
Thank you, megaphone.
Thank you, megaphone, right?
Right?
816, baby!
What's making that sound?
Oh, the button is.
Okay.
Let's see what we got here.
We got...
I still have not gotten the number one.
The tarot deck.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's, uh, reroll.
What do we have here?
Oh, it's a bunch of stuff we've gotten before.
Alright.
Let's go gambling.
Go gambling.
And trigger.
Okay.
That's fine.
I like that.
The kind of...
Some of the sound effects are annoying, so I don't forget to press the button.
You know what I mean?
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Um.
Ooh.
I got some meds.
Uh-oh!
Ah-oh!
Uh-uh!
Not good.
Um.
We're almost halfway there.
What are the pills?
Pain killers.
If only one pattern shows during a spin, transform its symbols into the most valued symbol.
Oh!
Unlockable by seeing one single pattern per spin.
What?
That's pretty good.
Yeah, it is pretty good.
Imagine everything turns into bells.
Oh, come on!
Okay.
Oh, come on.
I wonder if I'll ever get jackpot.
I want jackpot one day.
Oh gosh.
This is scary.
This is too scary.
Oh, I don't know, you guys.
I don't know.
Guys.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know.
It's good that this... I don't...
I have to be so, so lucky.
Not enough coins.
What a shame.
Ah.
Ah, GG.
That was, I guess, not bad for a first round, I guess, maybe?
Maybe for a first run.
That was pretty okay.
The mystery slowly unravels.
Mortis.
Welcome back.
Time to gamble.
Yeah, I already know how it works.
Go on.
What did we get?
Oh, wow.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I got mail for sure.
Corpse goes on slot plus cannot discard.
5% debt now.
Oh, wait, 5% debt now is 0%.
If this piece is inside a drawer at the end of the deadline, discard it.
Oh my gosh, we're getting Exodia!
Okay, cool.
Oh, I missed you guys, Stonks and Lucky Cat.
Oh, Stonks.
Let's see what else.
What is this?
The D4.
Exodia's skeleton.
The clicker.
Double A batteries.
Crystal sphere.
Dear diary.
Skull.
Corpse.
Corpse two.
Corpse three.
Corpse four.
So if...
Oh.
All of these are the same.
What's the...
Goes on slot plus cannot discard.
At the end of every deadline, spawn a random free charm in an available drawer for every corpse piece equipped.
Oh.
How I kind of...
How do you use this?
Plus one option at the telephone.
Just joining.
Good heavens.
Is that an arm in the drawer?
Don't worry about it.
Crystal sphere.
12% chance for the symbols, those, to have a chain modifier.
Oh.
Oh, here we go.
Double a battery is six?
Oh, sorry.
6% chance for the symbols.
Ah, the bell.
To have battery modifier.
Restore one charge.
Clicker.
I so...
The drawer noise is the worst.
15% chance for the symbols.
Lemon cherry to have the repetition modifier.
Repetition modifier.
Scoring a symbol with this modifier.
Re-triggers patterns.
Containing this symbol.
Oh, okay, cool.
Okay, shut up.
Shut up, shut up.
Okay.
Well, guys, I think I like this game.
I think, honestly, because it is, how do you, what do you, like, it is like Bellatro, but I don't have to think about numbers so much.
I think I like it so much more.
I like to watch the spins.
I like to watch...
The slot machine go I like it, I like it, I like it, I like it, I like it.
It's great if you don't like cards.
That's me, that's me, that's me!
So...
I
had fun You really picked it up fast Is the Vegas arc happening soon?
I'm going to Vegas I'm going to Vegas
In all honesty Because of the nature of my job And how I earn my income I would never go to Vegas Because I wouldn't do that to you guys.
I could never.
I'll come home with no pockets left.
I'll come home with no pockets.
Too much of a guilty conscious.
Yeah, for real.
I want to go to Vegas, though.
Just to like I want to see how the the the hotels but like the hotels are kind of like all dying like you know the themed ones like the Luxor and New York New York and what's the haunted one the pyramid
Gamba funds What if you vlog it Gambling funds No Listen to the song Numbers go off I don't think so Vegas funds No no no Oh isn't that the Luxor Oh oh yeah I was thinking Oh sorry I was thinking MGM I went to Vegas once When I was a little baby wisp And um uh so i obviously couldn't do anything i was just i they were like uh a baby ghost along until minto opens her own casino with blackjack and wifus what's a misanthropy wait do you have the sound thing maybe oh i i can't do certain sounds so i might have a sound thing.
I'm definitely one of those people that can't listen to, like, the sound of people eating.
And the sound of the fan, honestly, in this I had to turn it down.
It kind of...
Okay.
Like, do you know when you're, like, laying and you can hear your heartbeat?
It kind of happens with ghosts, too, because of, like, the way ectoplasm works.
But, like, you can hear your heartbeat and your ears, and that's, like, what the sound of fam sounds like to me.
This, you hear it?
I don't like it.
I hate it.
But, um, I went to Vegas and did not have a good time.
But, I got to pet a baby lion at MGM.
That's where we stayed at.
I got the pet a baby lion.
But I've heard that all of the themed hotels and stuff now suck.
So it makes me so sad.
And I don't want to go see the sphere.
I think that would make me...
I think that would make me have like...
I don't know.
Like I think I would go into hypnosis from it.
I would have some sort of mind break that...
about it Vegas has gotten unbelievably expensive in recent years but Gulfport Mississippi has casinos and nice beaches I like beaches it's not the casinos that I'm interested in though it's the fact that the hotels were different themes I'm really into stuff like that Minto mindlessly tapping on the slot machine like the old people are they all iPad run now ah You think you'll ever stream on the sphere?
I think I've once heard about how much it is to be on the sphere.
And, um...
No.
But how do they get the dancing cats on there, then?
Are we doing a second run or no?
No, I think that's... I'm going to call it today.
I do have a meeting in a bit, so...
Yeah.
Sorry, a bit of a shorter stream today.
Okay.
Sorry, sorry.
Do you like the Rainforest Cafe too?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Yes, yes, yes!
Darko thing is over there, the pig!
Pig Dodo for luck.
My luck is, luck is, my luck is literally negative stat, so...
You are now designated Big Mint.
Oh, well, I didn't mean to get bigger mint.
Make it a vlog or some video about exploring Vegas and make it attacks right off.
Phil Matara would join as a great enabler too.
I would go and maybe play like some blackjack.
No.
Maybe.
No!
I couldn't!
Don't force me!
I would never
It's only $450,000 for four hours on the sphere Okay, have you guys seen those videos though of like the cats dancing on the sphere Who's paying that then?
Oh Is there any way to hand a gift at your next con I've had this package since last year.
Who?
I don't remember if I'm doing gifts at...
Well, the next con I'm doing is the Idol Festival.
I'm not sure if I'm accepting gifts or not.
It really depends on who is at an event helping me and if they can give me gifts or not.
I think not wanting to gamble is admirable.
Good job, Minto.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm gonna be on the sphere.
Imagine like Chibi Minto on the sphere.
It might actually be... Wait, we can simulate this right now.
One moment, please.
We can pretend that this is gonna happen.
Hold on.
One second.
I can make this happen.
Maybe this.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna be on the sphere!
Wait, it's not happening.
Oh!
They told me I'd never amount to anything.
Oh, mom, I'm on the spear!
Oh, there we go.
Mom!
Mom, I'm on the spear!
Oh, say does a storm not better?
I was a...
National Anthem game.